mark are you doing a runner why I  figuring to do a walkabout in the  streets with Nigel why is it not  happening anymore mark white why not  gonna do it anymore are you going to do  a walker bites on the streets why not  tuned in leavin what we did I we did a  walkabout before we had planned to start  at 12 but in the end we started out and  didn't walk about first and put there  was one plan for this afternoon that's  what the UK press officer said so much  needs a lot to me you see what this is a  runner isn't it Sam huh do the same for  my story first it's very mature I just I  just stopped to speak to a conservative  member who wish me luck intention for  him were you going neither yeah I Delia  do you like to forget all this morning I  think it's been actually fantastic  really really pleased to report Nigel to  your sets up to Rochester it so great